Richard did start a whole conversations
when he wants to know if any of us ate
food out of the garbage because he eats
food out of the garbage yeah and then so
some of us were like well yeah once in a
while you throw something away and in
that second later you you change your
mind and he grabbed it and no Richard
had left something something in there
for days that he went like rooting
through they go get out or something it
was like half a day right it was me
while I was my wife and I loved this
place called Wawa that we'd get to go to
and order from 7-eleven it's a 7-eleven
in Pennsylvania is what was it but they
have the best sandwiches ever and she
ordered a BLT from there and she was
gonna save me some and she put it on the
on our debt on our dinner table and I
didn't know when I accidentally threw it
away like an hour later and then she
said oh where you didn't eat that BLT
and I said no where wasn't she told me
where it was I went and got it out of
the trash and ate it and was your other
trash on top of it a little bit yeah
yeah was it wrapped it kind of yeah it
was it was there was no diaper on top of
it or anything so it was fine
that's the bar yeah what is this I read
about you that you love hot dogs and
over the fourth of July weekend you ate
25 hot dogs is that true yeah oh yeah
yeah I mean my wife and I we used to go
you know before kovat we'd go to the
July 4th hot dog contest in Athens and
I'd eat tons of hot dogs there so this
time I just ordered a bunch of Nathan's
and you eat 20 25 over what period of
time a day probably the over the three
day July 4th weekend yeah were you
continually ordering in or did you just
get a whole stockpile I stockpile ding
and barbecue but there is a hotdog place
- did I order from near us that I
freaking love hot dog like hot dogs I
think there's like a hundred pig lips
and [ __ ]
what's droppings problem and yeah and
what be flips yes yeah the beef leaf lip
yeah and pig testicles
yeah at some of those yeah I love
southern France grant rocky rocky
mountain oysters have you ever had those
it's like fried Bowl balls they're so
good please your skin is like a pink hot
dog look at you I tried to like get a
nice light to make me look better but it
just highlights my greasy skin
you